новина з ти сама міс дарсі раз жити і
монету було 2 раката моя вина бурбуль
розум меншого корейському та студентам та
пройшла на мирну акцію протесту просто
вид нової а ну найкраща види
євроінтеграції
дівчина навчи колу що постраждали друг
беркуте cl5 шанс зачистка я зараз ти
дива
ну в такому вже очищу та гаразд яцо бачила
sibu фнафе ці гранати було виправлено тег
і кредитному вони були червона троянда дрібниця
осяде і я їх буду ще я так а чого мені
треба щуп я знав ще я пара мало і до
мінімуму тут на майдані та Аліна впала
поборола і рушити люди за маруся син
он вона змогла краще на все і друзів
роду чеки живучи на донбасі прийняв її
you prog гвинтику позицію якщо майдану
дівчина стала волонтерам біля скроні вам usb
і чи ви не лежати в них навіть сильніше
покращити вона не бували знаходять і ти
розміщу
треба розмитої але 1 пари ти нову помито
нові і ти не думаю що це я страта предка
робота ти думаю ще
ти воюєш на своєму фронті вина на
Донбасі that'sa нато правильні реформи
підняв і ширше долити україну вигляд Європи
вид овочі вимагав майдан поважаючи ліля
а он охопила щоку та й вкрай бургас
корупцію люстрою все проводилася, а не
на словах а по страшному
для панелі страхи цифроград абсолютно
xiv за метелики абсолютно всі нові імена
квиток на ipo батчат гра furby Петро йому
з жадібного кандидата що вони травня чи не
хотілося б шукають провини на донбасі не
було то один блок і тисячі жертв
вона його на пмж на що майдан бурхливий
відкидним там ще може зник курям
з приводу володію була вже на його можна